SPEAKER: This
presentation focuses
on registering and preparing
for the Associate Cloud Engineer
Certification Exam.
As you prepare for your
careers in a cloud-first world,
there's no better time
for you to get certified.
Certification is essential
in today's market
to validate mastery and
competency of technologies
that are critical to
business's success.
Certification provides
credibility and industry
recognition.
It is a testament to your skills
and proficiency in Google Cloud
Platform.
Certification is a
formal recognition
of professionals who meet
established knowledge, skills,
or competencies.
Certification often gives
you a competitive advantage
over somebody who
is not certified.
Certification
ensures that you are
on top of industry and
technology developments
and that your
skills are updated.
In 2013, 70% of IT professionals
believe that certifications
lead to a more effective staff.
That number is well
above 90% today.
One of our partners who took
the training and certifications
told us, GCP
certification proves
that an engineer not only
has real world experience,
but also has the
technical knowledge
to operate at the
level required.
The Associate Cloud
Engineer Track
includes the Associate Cloud
Engineer Certification.
This certification is an entry
point to a career in cloud
and to Google Cloud
certification.
The Associate Cloud
Engineer Certification
assesses your
technical knowledge,
including the ability to
plan, deploy, and ensure
successful operation
of a cloud solution.
Professional-level
certifications
identify individuals
who are capable of work
that is critical to modern
technology initiatives.
We make sure that these
certification exams actually
validate role-related skills.
They don't just assess
technical requirements
but also assess how you
map business requirements
to solutions developed
using Google Cloud.
Hands-on practice is
critical to success.
Exams must be taken at a
Kryterion-authorized. test
center.
Register early, as test center
availability is limited.
Questions can be multiple
choice or multiple select.
You can go back and review
earlier questions at any time
during the exam.
No paper, pens, or pencils
are allowed during testing.
In professional
exams, when answering,
there might be several
options that seem correct,
but there is only
one option that
satisfies both technical
and business requirements.
Choose the best, even if
the others might work.
We are testing for
Google best practices.
With Google Cloud certification,
you can differentiate yourself
from your peers.
You also have the opportunity
to network and exchange
ideas in the Google Cloud
Certified community.
Review the Exam
Guide to understand
the scope of the exam.
Complete all courses in the
Architecting with Google Cloud
Platform Specialization.
Spend sufficient time
to watch the videos,
complete all hands-on labs, and
review related documentation
in order to fully learn
concepts and practice working
with Google Cloud Platform.
Hands-on experience is
critical to success.
Practice with
additional hands-on labs
in the Qwiklabs platform.
Complete the self-paced labs
in the Cloud Architecture
Quest and GCP Essentials Quest.
You can also complete additional
labs on related topics.
Note that you can complete
these labs free of charge.
Check previous
communication sent to you
with Qwiklabs
credits information.
Assess your knowledge by taking
the Associate Cloud Engineer
Practice Exam.
You can take the practice
exam any number of times.
Register early for
a certification exam
at the nearest Kryterion
Testing Center.
You can find a Kryterion
Testing Center using
the locator website shown here.